hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
on my website move university I've found
thanks and enjoy the video
so this video is sort of a continuation
of the previous video on sphingolipids
so we talked about the different classes
and I kind of want to show example in
this video so the first one we'll talk
about is a sphingomyelin
so we said sphingomyelin z' are
basically phospho Stingo lipids that
specifically have phospho choline or
phosphoethanolamine as their polar head
group so here this Fingal myelin has a
sphingosine backbone and purple has some
fatty acyl group here in brown and then
the polar head group is a phospho
alcohol so which alcohol is this this
alcohol is from ethanol amine so now
this thing this question here says which
alcohol is this polar head group coming
from that that's different from asking
what is the polar head group the polar
head group entirely is phospho
ethanolamine right but it's just asking
which alcohol is this polar head group
coming from and that's just this portion
so that would be ethanol amine
but that's how a that's an example of a
sphingomyelin next up a cerebroside
okay so cerebral sides were a subclass
of glycosphingolipids right this is a
neutral glycolipids and cerebroside
specifically only have one sugar
attached to them so again sphingosine
backbone in purple the brown we has a
fatty acyl group and in blue here we
have a sugar attached as the polar head
group which sugar is this well
this sugar is glucose right and what
types of tissue membranes would you
expect this to be president we mentioned
in the previous video that if the if the
polar head group is a glucose we expect
that to be a non neural plasma membranes
right we wouldn't expect that to be a
neuro flat on membranes if this was if
had has been galactose we would have put
neural plasma membranes but again three
both sides have only one sugar and this
here is that one sugar glucose okay
globocide so Globa sides we said could
have two or more sugars attached there's
their polar head group and they're also
neutral so right so these guys have an
overall charge of zero
just like cerebral sides right because
these are glycosuria lipids so here the
polar head group is just these two
sugars attached together and if you look
at this and I just asked you which
disaccharide would that be if it was
separated from these this uh this
sphingolipid this would be lactose this
disaccharide would be lactose because
this here is galactose and this is
glucose and this here is a beta one four
linkage
this is carbon number one two three four
five six on this one and this here is
one two three four five six on this one
and here this is specifically this is
the anomeric carbon and because it's
going up this is beta okay
one more thing I want to actually go
back real quick remember global sides
and three besides are neutral so there's
no charge anywhere on this and with the
cerebroside also no charge anywhere this
Fingal milan right it does have charges
right it has a negative charge here and
a positive charge here so overall has a
neutral charge but if this if this
alcohol portion was a different alcohol
then we might we might have a case in
which we wouldn't we would have an
overall charge okay and the last example
for gangliosides it's not an actual
example of ganglia of an elbow ganglia
side but this is what a see alec acid
looks like
so if we see specifically in the chair
form so here I've drawn n-acetyl
pneumatic acid and I've done my best to
color code this alright so this is a
sialic acid here so the n-acetyl and the
name comes from this portion over here
on the bottom left right color coded and
light pink and blue so that's the NS
little portion and the acidic portion is
of course this carboxylate group up here
right it's in the deprotonated form and
it's carrying a negative charge right so
this is why they are so if you see
basically if you see something if you
see a cerebroside right that's just
something that has at least two sugars
attached as the polar head group and
then if you see two or more right if you
see two or more sugars and you see
something like this if you see a
carboxylic acid portion attached to a
chair that looks like this then you have
a sialic acid attached to the
oligosaccharide polar head group and in
that case you would have a ganglia side
so i encourage you to maybe draw some of
these on your own practice
kind of be able to recognize them and I
hope that helps thanks for watching yo
if you found that video helpful don't
forget a like comment subscribe for more
content and if you know anybody who
might find the videos helpful then
please share with them Thanks happy
studying